here's a deacon what guests had to say
after the show okay we are back now what
is the likelihood sanctions against
Russia will have a positive effect Jim
SS well I think they could I mean yeah I
think he you know we've seen a lot of
kleptocracy x' before you know I mean
there's a lot of tyrants in the world
who have made no distinction between
their own personal bank accounts and the
country's Treasury Mobutu remember him
in Zaire and Marcos and the Philippines
and Papa Doc and Haiti I mean this is
common practice but but Putin could
actually be the worst yeah I think we
got to remember that Russia is a dying
and decaying power you know they're kind
of sustained because energy prices are
high they have no serious economy their
population is shrinking this is not an
ascended power this is a power that is
collapsing and they're trying puttan and
the person of Putin trying to you know
live the days of Russian Empire we
should try to expedite that as fast as
possible and sanctions might be the key
and Obama deserves credit for the tough
sanctions he imposed two days ago Jane
Obama never deserves credit get that
through your head he's always weak and
emboldened in people there are those
zombie lies
I thought that only worked when I did it
okay
Oh in your power now I guess I am does
the Reverend bar negate it goes nd does
the news media's constant reference to
the n-word instead of using the actual
word in context help or hinder national
discussion on race and racism that's
interesting question well you know I
don't know if the constant referral into
the n-word is in the problem with the
race discussion is we don't really want
to have a race discussion right and we
don't want to unpack how race is behind
the denial of Medicaid how race is
behind these voter suppression laws you
know in our state for instance the
Speaker of the House Tillis said he was
passing a voter integrity law but you
wait until after Shelby after Shelby
someone says now that the headache has
been removed that's a code word and then
you change 40 different laws of our
state laws and every law that you change
from same-day registration early voting
to straight ticket all our laws that
will impact African Americans and other
minorities and women we don't want to
talk about how every sense that Kevin
Phillips came up that so-called white
Southern Strategy people have used these
code words so I'm not so much where it
some time about folk who use in or the
actual word what I'm worried about are
people who engage in policies that have
a systemic discriminatory impact on
minorities
Nate what must happen for the public to
consider Obamacare a success or at least
a wise idea yeah that's a great question
for someone who crunches the numbers
well it's a hard question to answer
because these are policies are going to
take years to go into effect
you know Obamacare was trying to solve a
problem where you have however many
Americans who are uninsured still most
people were happy with their insurance
that means the range is affecting is a
modestly sized specific incise minority
of the population but you know will they
have health care that they like will
they see that it's cheaper or not or
will their premiums have gone up you
know I don't think all the rhetoric you
hear right now from Republicans and
Democrats is going to really matter very
much in five years and people have
experience where they lose a job and it
lets care where they find we Hank about
a poll that said something like
three-quarters of Republicans who got
Obamacare were happy with it right even
ones where they were their policy that's
what I was saying before is that the
number of people who have been in this
group uninsured people it's a big
problem in my view but it's still a
minority of the populations so well
there you can make some people very
pleased because now they can get care
when they didn't have before and
everyone else a little angry because
their taxes might be well I I voted for
it close and and the law was not perfect
to get only the Democrats know how to
brag about themselves like you do and
that's what they need to learn how to do
unfortunate that it was a partisan vote
and should the law perhaps be amended
yes it should there are things that
don't work well but a lot of the
provisions are hugely popular and the
number of uninsured is going down so in
the net it is a positive and
unfortunately I vomit is not telling the
story very well because I do think in
the country when more people understand
what the law actually does it will
become more popular you know one of the
things that I struggled with was my
Republican something I call them extreme
because we hasn't good Republican my
granddaddy was one they are claimed to
love Jesus so much in Jesus way if he
didn't do anything went around setting
up free health clinics and so why in the
world is so against health care secondly
in
state with all of the attempts to stop
it we were the fifth highest state to
receive the impact from bamaca people
signing up do another success I prayed
to live long enough that my daughter who
has hydrocephalus would not be able to
be denied health care that was one of my
prayers and they are millions of other
parents in this country that are glad
now that their shoes will be able health
health care does seem a little strange
to me that the the party that always
claims the mantle would be all Jesus
lovers do things that I can't imagine
Jesus approving of like stopping a bus
full of children from coming into the
country we do I mean that just doesn't
seem like mb or gay doesn't seem like
Jesus who will cater to the psyche and
the lepers and the hookers with every
you know gay people and go how you make
me sick Fay 11 the other it just doesn't
seem Jesus like to me and I agree with
you to a certain extent that some treat
the border issue not realizing that
their children down there but just this
week Glenn Beck has sent you know
caravans for supplies and soccer balls
and things do to help Patrol I mean
right yeah right and he also said it
probably is the greatest threat to my
career so I would say to Glenn Beck hang
out with different people if you're if
this is a great threat to you because
your fans will hate you for it maybe
your fans aren't good people and if you
want to send something don't send ball
send a change in immigration policy and
let's welcome these children all right
that's in fact
a deal I want to tell you something when
it comes to atheism I'm an atheist too
when it comes to those folk that say
that Jesus is on the side of bigots and
on the side of those that hurt people at
that kind of God I don't know him either
I believe in a God of justice a God of
love and a God that cares for the
stranger and welcomes people regardless
of who they are that's good to know
you're nothing if not a convenient I
always had that about you what a
convener this guy is a word I into
Congress George in the world of 60s
television was there a sort of gay
underground from which you could draw
some support or did you just have to go
it alone oh yeah who are the other gay
people then there must have helped that
was a period of the AIDS epidemic no
this is the 60s oh I thought you said in
60s when you were on Star Trek he's
saying was there a gay underground that
you could you know other people I'm
guessing on there like in perhaps her
there were what's called gay bars hmm
and there was an organization called the
Mattachine Society which was organized
and actually articulating for equality
for LGBT people so there was that but I
had a career that I wanted passionately
I love acting yeah and I knew that if I
were out and advocating but but and then
he's asking about support from other
people like were in your same shoes when
they were in the 60s television you
couldn't come out I'm just asking like
you know mr. Drucker perhaps on
petticoat junction I always thought he
was a little right oh well
you know I'm just saying you know there
were gay people bellows on my dream of
jeannie' I mean come on yeah so there
there were all these support people they
were carpenter on McHale's Navy giving
away I mean these people were playful
yes but I didn't want that kind of
career right I wanted you know a career
where I can grow and write if you do
some you know substantial roles all
right and if I were asking for support
as a gay man forget it right all right
be an act next week I'll tell you who
was gay on hee haw thank you very much
Real Time with Bill Maher ask bill and
his guests your questions right after
the show at hbo.com or on Twitter